European Union countries have agreed to
put a cap on the price of Russian oil
currently at sixty dollars a barrel the
move aims to reduce moscow's ability to
fund its war in Ukraine with revenue
from petroleum exports
the EU joins the United States and other
G7 nations in sanctioning Russian oil
which recently traded at about 65 a
barrel the measure will come into effect
on Monday and intensifies Western
pressure on the Kremlin over its
invasion of Ukraine European commission
president Ursula fonderlein said the
price cap would have a wide range of
implications
it will stabilize Global energy markets
because it allows some Russian seaborne
oil to be traded broker transported by
EU operators to third countries
as long as it is sold below the cap
so this price cap will benefit directly
emerging and developing economies
and it will be adjustable over time so
that we can react to Market developments
together with our partners We Stand
United and firm in our opposition to
Russia's atrocious War
let's get some more on this from our
Russia analyst Constantine Eggert who's
in the Lithuanian Capital uh Vilnius can
you tell us what effect will the oil
price cap likely have for Russia
I don't think it will have a huge effect
Frankly Speaking because uh there are
many ways of bypassing this
um this oil price cap which concerns
essentially mostly those who ensure the
shipments and those who transport
Russian oil for example uh you may claim
or Russians may claim that the oil is
sold at 59.99 while after that for
example the same country for example
China or India will pay an extra price
for let us say Russian wheat which is
not banned by sanctions so I think it
will have more psychological effect it
will have some pressure on certain
companies that will for some of the
insurance companies and transport
companies be to be more cautious but it
will not be a disaster for the Kremlin
and if we could just turn to the reason
for this price cap the war in Ukraine
there's been heavy fighting again near
Bahamut in conditions described as
similar to those of World War One what's
at stake here
oh Frankly Speaking um if you look at
military analysis for example uh the
British Institute for the study of War
um those people who are professional
many of them ex-military uh they do not
understand what is actually the aim game
here for Russia Russia has been engaged
in and around bahmoud for several months
now it spends a lot of material and a
lot of Manpower uh on what seems to be
at best a tactical gain if this gain is
actually achieved uh I think what we did
what we're dealing with is with
um certainly lack of overall strategy uh
by the Russian commanders and by Putin
finally with regard to what they are
doing in the east of Ukraine this battle
is kind of fallen into a mosaic of
different small battles each of them is
not part of some kind of bigger
overarching plan and into that Mosaic
the Russian army is reportedly deploying
newly mobile civilized troops on the
front line will that change anything
I don't think so these people are well
for lack of better word not being too
politically correct I cannot afford it
for Putin because he actually cannot
bear let us say the Chinese board or the
Finnish body he can't transport the
whole Russian army to Ukraine so it has
to uh basically rely on untrained
concrets which are going to die on Mars
what is going to follow that and that is
my firm conviction is another
mobilization then another mobilization
it's another matter that it may be
conducted under some kind of other guys
but people will be
called up this will continue and there's
going to be more Russian deaths on the
front
okay Russia analyst Constantine Egger
thank you for that insight
thank you